thinking back to something a mentor said
to the two of you individually maybe
even before you met one another what was
it and what is it what statement was
that or mantra that never left you
because you're very Bradbury could be
done I it's anything but the thing that
most affected me was a script doctor
very good script doctor that I had and
and and of the script I've written he
was one of my favorite trips ultimately
but what she said this is brilliant I
absolutely love it now here's the notes
and and but in fact she said that I was
brilliant and that she loved it I
thought well what the heck was a few
notes I'm brilliant and I love it so I
think you know crazy flattery you know I
really sort of the weight of allowing
somebody to be feel special and be
special
it was crazy flattery that all of the
notes seemed like nothing so you were
the biggest biggest piece of advice was
that hey what you're doing has super
value now here's the work and just going
on that thing where I was allowed to
have Super Value at the top of the
journey really got me through I thought
was nothing
so it was note mmm um in terms of of me
the mentors were they've told me you
know it's funny because you know the
mentors really have guided me have been
you know Rod Serling Ray Bradbury
Guillermo del Toro and what really
inspired me was the fact that these are
guys who just come from enormous
enthusiasm creative enthusiasm and raise
one thing Ray said to me what he said
don't look outside yourself look within
and so it's again finding identify me
there was one time when he and I was
sitting together and I said I just
figure out what business you're in
I said not writer I said you're in the
Ray Bradbury business and he said yes
that's exactly right and what he saw
what he was doing was creating something
that no one else could create and he
told me that he spent he wrote every day
for ten years before he wrote a single
line a single word that was uniquely his
and then one day he
that down and he wrote the words the
lake and he wrote a short story based on
the time when he was a little boy when
he was eight years old he and a little
girl friend who was seven when swimming
in Lake Michigan and he came out and she
never did she drowned and her strength
had her coming back as a ghost and he
told me that when he finished the story
tears were streaming down his face and
he knew he'd written something that no
one else could have written it came
specifically from his experience and his
soul and he said it took it and it took
another two years of writing every day
before he could write something again
that was uniquely his and they got to
where he could do it again and again and
again and he became Ray Bradbury because
we determined to do that and so I
thought that was a great lesson to say
okay what are you creating what can you
create that isn't something that's just
an imitation what others are doing
but that's unique to you that no one
else could have created that you create
something fresh in the world that's
truthful and meaningful and and then you
know you've done something what's doing
so that's that's been a great
inspiration to me these new people just
are so afraid of being hurt they they do
the safe thing so that somebody says
that's not very good so I know it was a
piece of trash I've just read everybody
else is doing so you do put yourself out
for far greater vulnerability but then
what's ugly original something I mean if
you do something original but then to
not do so is slowly slow so on a slowly
soul-killing yes event quickly I I
failed to sell quickly I fell over
myself oh yeah so yes it is it's like
being worn down by the ocean yeah
secretly you just does and so one of the
things like as an example when we work
together for TV if we got a note it
wouldn't matter if it's a dumb note or
not sometimes the notes were great the
sentencer notes were John and we made a
pact that no matter how dumb it felt
initially we would not hand in that
craft until we were able to work that
note in in a way which made it there so
every draft had be better than the
previous draft and so no matter how
challenging the notes were we would find
a way to do that and my foot my friend
Doug Hayes who was one of the great
directors of The Twilight Zone he did I
have the poles are in the after hours
and Hallie man
many other episodes he he was also very
good writer
and he said when you get notes the
executives giving the notes are often
not lighters and so the note the
solution they're offering may not work
but that there's a concern under the
note there's something that's not
working for them and what they're saying
the solution is may not be the right
solution and never put in something in
your script that doesn't work but you
have to look at what the concern is you
have to figure out what the concern is
and address that and if you come up with
an alternative that does work they'll be
satisfied even if the solution they
offered isn't the one that you utilize
as long as the concern is addressed and
has a great piece of wisdom so you
really want to maintain a pride of
workmanship and not just so you know you
never never talk about first of those
know that you you don't defect to the
audience give it you give it your best
you know what because it represents you
and you make it represent you and you
see it on people on like an assembly
lines where you develop something you
know care versus something you care
about and you take a little bit of reel
out a little bit of pride in what you do
and which i think is just critical to
the way he needs work and so yes we
would put up that fight but I always
remember to the you know when we're
teaching there was a woman who shared
with me she had a an action piece the
man and woman into action thing and it
was like non-stop action non-stop action
going and going and going and the woman
said who was the executive well it sort
of drags in the second act really drags
and she flared but you enough to keep it
to herself and she will let me look at
that it was dragging in the second act
and said how could it drag there was
non-stop action and then it hit her on
the way home that it wasn't it was
non-stop action it's that in act 1 she
had not set up us caring sufficiently
about the leads and the outcome for
those leads for us to care what kind of
threat they were facing because we
didn't care and so she said okay well
she's going to like deepen the
characters and much more focus on their
need and our
within their journey she's going to slow
down the second act still keeping it
exciting which is going to slow it down
so that we really know what the struggle
is about and the reason that they want
that it seemed flow was we just didn't
care and the executive then said this is
much better now it really rolls along
now she couldn't analyze why she didn't
care in the second act but she was dead
on by the second act we were getting
restive and simply didn't care because
we didn't know who was in the struggle
and so why would we care so sometimes
they don't communicate what's really
going on they just know that it's
falling flat yeah it's not their
responsibility to make the script work
it's your responsibility and so they've
hired you because you're a professional
writer and and so they mean everyone
yeah well you know exactly just get a
bad rap most of them are very smart and
very talented and very driven in their
the business business because they love
it and everyone wants the script to work
everyone wants a movie to work nobody
wants to create something that fails and
so but it's very challenging I mean it's
it's hard to make anything good and so
but but if you decide that you're going
to give everything your best effort
you're going to bring everything you've
got to every job that's a good starting
point and and so that's been true in my
whole career I started in animation and
whether it was writing Smurfs or space
command I mean it's and I don't just
write things with an S starting the
title but but you know you you say okay
I'm going to I'm going to bring
everything I've got to this and that
that gives you a certain professional
integrity and the executives that
they're paid to get a sense of a story
but you're paid because you have the
analysis in your brain and that you've
said okay there's something wrong I have
to figure out what is wrong specifically
but they've picked up that something is
wrong and you're probably accurate but
sometimes you'll need to have that's
where it's good have friends who are
very talented so if you're stuck you can
call them say look food stops being
around a little bit I gotta figure this
out and Elaine is my sounding board so
for instance and sometimes it'll be like
okay this works but how can we make this
better how can we go deeper how can it
be
more meaningful and that's a very
important
you